do you remember when we were in the car
nope next question the first the first
night that we met
yeah do you remember what I asked you
are you guys sad oh yeah I do remember
that Comics are sad right are you guys
sad yeah you're like are you guys should
have known then yeah but I I don't think
I was sad but I wasn't accessing all of
my emotions I had my walls up right
because I I would not
I didn't like the fact that's a question
I was like well I got to do so many
jokes because we're not getting into any
[__] here I was blocking out any sort of
realness yeah because I wasn't a real
person back then yeah um and what do you
think your change into being a real
person like how did that happen well
I'll show you
[Applause]
sorry sorry but it's for the bit so you
motive me so look look I'll show you
I just float away uh yeah what
well since because I'm on I'm never on
the podcast oh God this was a mistake so
maybe we can talk about that stuff what
therapy and stuff well it's just like
the real stuff about you
like oh the weather outside is frightful
you're getting dangerously close to
having my heart beat
it's going so freaking fast I'm gonna
have to take an Alprazolam after this
you're so dumb yeah
um okay can I just ask questions oh my
god dude we might have to cut some out
that's fine okay
um what was it about me that you oh like
knew that I was
um gonna be your wife
you're obviously okay look there's wife
material right you're obviously wife
material but besides that
it was your energy you were just
absolutely the most
even killed person that I've ever met
and I need that I'm nuts okay and you
were just fun from jump and like not
serious about yourself like you didn't
take yourself too seriously that's a big
thing for me when people take [__] too
seriously I take themselves too
seriously and don't go with the joke
that's a huge thing for me yeah your
whole family is so good at just going
with the gym yeah I I it's really hard
for me to deal with
um anything yeah it's hard for me to
deal with emotions and stuff and like um
you know uh but yeah so you're getting
really good at it though thanks or it's
a skill that you are um improving
actively so that's I am trying yeah
um but yeah that's uh you are
um you're just great You're great and
I've I say it on my podcast and
sometimes I honestly say like you're my
angel and I don't actually like the way
I say that because it you're an angel
and I am lucky enough to be around you
oh that's how I like to say it better
than me but I say you're my angel and I
don't like the way that says every time
I say that I'm like I kind of cringe
because it's not I don't think that's
right to say but yeah I'm all right dude
wanna hear why I like you
or why I fell in love with you I met you
and I had
um been watching I watched your vines in
college wow like probably let's see I
was 25 or six when I met you so when I
was like 22 um
and I remember thinking like I bet I
would like him or like I bet we would
get along you were right
and then I saw you perform and then
um
you were so
I liked you so much more than I had ever
liked anybody that I feel like it it
um jump started my own
like journey to becoming a better person
oh wow yeah because I was like I need to
really get my [__] together if I'm gonna
be like worth him oh gosh yeah and so I
really really did that
[Music]
why are you seem like that's bad no it's
great I loved you so much I was like
you're dealing with that kind of actual
connection is what do you mean it's so
hard to actually feel all those emotions
yeah yeah we've had it we've had quite a
journey together
[Music]